this is fiery cross island it's a little
more than one square mile in size and
it's home to a Chinese military base
there's a 10,000 foot airstrip an
advanced radar station a missile defense
system and about 200 troops but the
strangest thing about fiery cross island
is that two years ago it didn't exist
and neither did the six other Chinese
military bases that have been built on
man-made islands in the South China Sea
if you look at this satellite image from
2014 you can see huge Chinese ships
collecting around remote reefs in the
Spratly Islands an archipelago in the
South China Sea in this image these
ships are rapidly pumping sand and rock
up onto the reef they're building
islands and less than a year later the
Chinese had seaports air bases and
buildings on their new island and the
world had taken notice we continue our
look this morning on what China does not
want you to see the superpower is
reclaiming land in seven spots in the
South China Sea
adding on average more than three and a
half acres every day see what these
islands China's trying to lay claim to
one of the most important areas of ocean
in the world the South China Sea the
South China Sea is incredibly rich in
natural resources 11 billion barrels of
oil 190 trillion cubic feet of natural
gas and 10% of the world's fisheries
most importantly though 30% of the
world's shipping trade flows through
here to the booming population centers
and economic markets of Southeast Asia
it's an extremely important body of
water and right now five countries lay
claim to some part of it
now most countries base their claim off
the UN law of the Seas which says a
country's territorial waters extend 200
miles off their Shore an area called the
exclusive economic zone or EEZ countries
have exclusive rights to all the
resources and trade and their EEZ it's
their sovereign territory so for example
any oil that's found within 200 miles
off the coast of Vietnam belongs
exclusively to Vietnam
but any area that isn't in an e easy is
regarded as international waters and it
falls under UN maritime law which means
everybody shares it now every country in
the South China Sea region uses this
200-mile easy threshold to determine its
claims all except China China argues
they have a historical claim to the
South China Sea dating back to naval
expeditions in the 15th century and they
mark it using a really confusing border
called the nine - line following World
War two Japan who had dominated the
entire region lost all control of its
surrounding seas China use the moment to
claim the South China Sea by drawing
this imprecise line on the map that
encompassed 90% of the South China Sea
it became known as the nine - line and
when the UN established that 200-mile
easy in 1973 China stuck to its own line
refusing to clarify its boundaries and
ignoring claims by other countries now
that brings us to the Spratly Islands
it's a remote barely inhabited cluster
of islands currently claimed by China
Vietnam the Philippines and Malaysia the
Spratlys are both geographically and
symbolically at the heart of the South
China Sea
that's because any country that can
claim the Spratly Islands can extend
their EE Z's to include them and gain
exclusive rights to the surrounding
territory but it's really hard to
legitimately claim uninhabited piles of
sand so a few nations have built small
buildings and ports on their claimed
islands and even stuck a few people
there but China believes all the Spratly
Islands belong to them
which brings us back to why they're
building Islands they're installing
military bases on these new artificial
islands took the dispute to a whole new
level
showing how China is potentially willing
to defend its claims with force now this
is about when the United States took
notice while the US has no claim in the
South China Sea
it is the world's lone superpower and
uses its massive Navy to defend
international waters but China sees the
US presence in the area as an
encroachment in their backyard when a US
destroyer ship sailed just 12 miles off
the shore of one of China's man-made
islands in the Spratlys China sent out
their own destroyer and a patrol boat as
a warning
China's building these islands in order
to increase control around the
surrounding waters using a strategy that
they've deemed the cabbage strategy
where they surround a contestant island
with as many ships as possible in May of
2013 China sent several ships to a
youngin shoal which is just a hundred
and five nautical miles off the coast of
the Philippines well within that
200-mile EEZ the Philippines has eight
soldiers stationed there
like wrapping leaves around a cabbage
the Chinese sealed off the Philippines
access TOI youngin shoal with fishing
boats surveillance ships and Navy
destroyers creating blockades so that
the Filipinos can't receive shipments of
food and supplies by building their own
man-made islands China is essentially
building naval bases the more islands
they have the more ships they can
support and the more territory they can
slowly take control of and the Chinese
cautiously use the cabbage strategy in
the Spratly Islands taking over
contested territory but in small steps
avoiding the possibility of igniting a
bigger conflict but the disputes are
intensifying countries are now actively
arresting trespassers in waters that
they claim and China could go a step
further since 2015 they've threatened to
declare an air identification zone above
the South China Sea declaring that all
aircraft that fly through it would need
Chinese permission now publicly China
insists that their intentions are not
militaristic but their actions say
otherwise
and it's heightening tensions in the
region Steve Bannon who sits on the US
National Security Council and who is one
of President Trump's closest advisors is
almost certain that the US will go to
war in the South China Sea we're going
to warn in South China Sea I was a
sailor there a naval officer we're gonna
warn the South China Sea in five to ten
years aren't we
there's no doubt about it but for now
the disputes remain only in the legal
and diplomatic realms that only
occasionally break into minor clashes in
July 2016 the International Court at The
Hague ruled in favor of the Philippines
who charged China with invading their
rightful territory in the South China
Sea but China dismissed the ruling and
enforcement of the law doesn't seem
likely even from the US who released a
vague statement urging the two countries
to clarify their claims and work
together to resolve their disputes which
is another way of saying we don't really
want to deal with this in fact as the
conflict escalates and international
courts get involved the u.s. is stuck
position on one hand they do not want to
risk provoking a conflict with China but
on the other they want China to stop
bullying their allies in the region up
until now the US has managed the
situation by continuing to patrol
through the South China Sea it's also
likely that the US would fly fighter
jets above the sea if China actually
does declare an air identification zone
these are symbolic but effective ways of
keeping China in check while not getting
too involved in the details of the
conflict so far the disputes in the
South China Sea have not become violent
but countries are starting to defend
their claims by increasing troop numbers
weaponizing their territory and
provoking each other it's a complex
situation that will continue to gain
international attention for better or
for worse
[Music]